white house staffers not happy that some
of the mainstream media are not giving
enough credit for their historic wins
one complaining on twitter with this
quote a historic confirmation judge
jackson is justice jackson historic low
for unemployment claims historic
international effort to provide relief
on putin's price hike
so that's an effort to provide police
relief
can't find coverage she goes on to say
of any of it in the newsletter that
purports to report on the white house
though critics point to president
biden's growing crises as the real story
inflation is at a historic 40-year high
americans face the highest annual
increase in food costs since 2008 and
the president's crisis at the southern
border is also historic as dhs projects
18 000 illegal crossings per day and the
unprecedented problems for his son
hunter biden seem to be picking up some
steam so he certainly has quite a bit on
his plate uh katie do you feel like the
coverage i i know the answer to this
when i asked you this before i said the
coverage is unfair
well i would say if you are a democratic
administration in the white house
complaining about coverage in the d.c
press whether it's politico or any other
outlet then you know that your policies
are not being are not going well and
that the state of the country has a
problem i mean this is not going to
having good press and politico is not
going to change the reality for the
majority of americans in this country
the lower middle classes who are dealing
with the inflation they're dealing with
the employment picture the small
business owners the people who are on
the border and leaving the democratic
party in droves as a result of the open
border policies and so it's that's just
an indication that the administration is
having a really tough time breaking
through with their accomplishments as a
result of all the other things that are
going wrong for them yeah jessica you
know i'm always struck by the site and
it made me think of president obama when
he was at that ceremony the other day
and they said you know what should they
do about the midterms and he said just
tell the story tell the story of
everything that's good right um but i
think more and more especially in the
world we live in right now people know
the story uh they hear they get
bombarded with media whether it's on the
right or the left but they know the
reality of what they're feeling in their
lives and i don't know that it matters
to katie's point whether or not you know
politico is nice enough to them it
definitely doesn't because the average
american who is going to go out and vote
isn't reading politico right maybe
they'll see some press clippings of
whatever put together but the story of
how your life is going is told in the
places we go every day at the grocery
store at the gas pump when you talk to
your family your friends relatives etc
on the phone and obviously that story at
this particular moment is not a
fantastic one for the democrats i will
say though that i do think partisanship
is really important in this because i
heard a lot of people a lot of
conservatives complaining about even the
coverage that president trump was
getting in some conservative outlets
saying oh they're not pro-trump enough
that these people are rhinos people who
i've known my entire adult life and been
following the news to be quite
conservative people so that any little
criticism seems enormous and ballooned
out of control when these are still
people that are going to line up and
check that box for president trump
anytime he's on the ballot and as an
example on the democratic side you know
liberals hate chuck todd now they think
that they think chuck todd is
a conservative essentially because
well but this is what i'm saying this is
what goes on in these bubbles because he
does lead with inflation stories he has
ron johnson senator ron johnson on all
the time who repeated you know the big
lie about the election and he doesn't
push back hard enough so everyone lives
in these little bubbles especially when
you're meet the press kind of watcher
right they're just complaining about
whatever's happening to their party
jonathan carl did a long piece last
weekend all about these things that we
just pointed out that just are facts of
of what's going on jesse whitehouse says
some nerve whining about press coverage
the press got him in the white house
exactly when they covered up the laptop
it's not a good look to wine that would
be like if greg gave me a yacht and i
complained to greg that the yacht was
not the color that i wanted and greg
would just say give me the yacht back i
would and that's what the media can do
the media created the biden presidency
the media could destroy the biden
presidency like this they start
reporting on what's really in that
laptop this presidency is over and to
say that they don't do this they don't
do that it's not just the laptop they
don't cover crime they don't cover the
border they don't cover his mental
unfitness and we're acting like this
presidency is just kind of hitting a
rough patch it's a disaster and the
press corps is just wondering like when
the easter egg roll is gonna really go
down they really don't treat this guy
the way they should but every presidency
greg says you know oh you're not
covering our good story enough yeah yeah
they're always complaining but uh this
fellow over here made a very good point
i uh to prove jessica that we are not as
partisan as we look i am going to
compliment the white house on the
confirmation of the supreme court
justice uh they all looked well groomed
so the white house should be upset uh
the old line about loyalty is you don't
shoot inside the tent right and we kind
of know
studies show that the media and the
democrats share the same tent it's the
equivalent when when when chuck todd
criticizes the white house it's the
equivalent of you know will smith
getting upset because his wife you know
is talking smack about their marriage
that's what you're hearing right now
you're not supposed to do that but the
other question and it's and when you
said that it's a disaster it is a
the administration right now isn't is in
bad shape and you got the midterms
approaching and it looks like it's going
to be a blood path the polling
especially on crime and the economy just
looks really really grim but why aren't
the democrats panicking and i feel like
there is something up their sleeve like
they always have i mean let's face it i
mean what is the next big hoax you had
you know you had the collusion you had
the p tape you had to find people hoax
and you buried laptop they're gonna need
something super big and super fake
coming up to shake this box and i
you know it's coming you know it's
coming and it's gonna have everybody
scrambling and then all of a sudden you
find out it's not gonna be real but it
might be too late don't you think that's
happening now i'm really nervous
i'm telling you i don't know why you had
time i don't know what it is but it's
going to be something really big that
just makes there's nothing bigger than
the p-tape yeah
that's just that's true i have it on vhs
oh that's where it is yes
i hate being here she's thinking about
some of the stuff on that laptop i'm
like yeah i don't know which is worse
not safe for work at all yeah um all
right cnn's brian stelter getting
schooled by a college freshman have you
seen this back and forth it's next hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else